programming throwdown episode 47 ruby take it away jason hey everybody. We have a cool episode coming up on Ruby. We also have a lot of interesting questions and feedback and a lot of mail. Actually, the mail has gone up by, what, maybe a factor of five or something? A lot. There's a lot of new people out here.
Programming Throwdown 第 47 期，Ruby 专题。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。我们即将带来一期关于 Ruby 的精彩节目。我们还收到了很多有趣的问题、反馈和大量的邮件。事实上，邮件量增加了，大概有五倍左右吧？非常多。有很多新听众加入了。
We don't know where you came from, but welcome. Actually, if you guys just shoot us an email or post on facebook or g plus tell us where you found uh if you're if you're new to the show let us know where you came from because we we got a ton of people uh uh in the show very recently at least based on the emails and our very loose, hand-wavy statistics. And so, yeah, let us know. We're curious. So, cool. So one of the emails we got is from Jaroslaw Piskorski.
我们不知道你们从哪里来，但欢迎你们。其实，如果你们能给我们发封邮件，或者在 Facebook 或 Google+ 上留言，告诉我们你们是怎么找到我们的，或者如果你是新听众，请告诉我们你们的来源，因为最近节目里突然多了很多人，至少从邮件和我们那些非常粗略、随意的统计数据来看是这样。所以，是的，告诉我们吧。我们很好奇。好的，那么，我们收到的一封邮件来自 Jaroslaw Piskorski。
Sorry if I messed that up. So he's, I don't know if he's a statistician, but he knows a lot more about statistics than Patrick and I do combined. And he added a lot of information on r um one of the things about r that we didn't know is that the r the syntax in r and for people who don't know r was the language we covered last month episode 46 that's right so the c uh the the syntax of R is almost identical to the syntax in statistics textbooks. So you can open up a statistics textbook, take some equations from that, and almost type them verbatim in R, which is pretty cool. Also, he mentions a lot of things R does. There's a lot of the things, there's overlap
抱歉，如果我把名字读错了。我不知道他是不是统计学家，但他对统计学的了解比我和 Patrick 加起来还要多。他补充了很多关于 R 的信息。关于 R，有一点我们之前不知道，那就是 R 的语法——对于那些不知道 R 的人，R 是我们上个月第 46 期节目介绍的语言——没错，R 的语法几乎和统计学教科书里的语法一模一样。所以你可以打开一本统计学教科书，从中摘取一些公式，几乎可以逐字输入到 R 中，这非常酷。此外，他还提到了 R 的很多功能。其中有很多与 MATLAB、NumPy 和 SciPy 重叠的地方。
there with MATLAB and with NumPy and SciPy. But they're worth mentioning. They're interesting. And so definitely go to ProgrammingThrowdown.com Check out our blog and go to the R episode.
但它们值得一提。它们很有趣。所以一定要访问 ProgrammingThrowdown.com，查看我们的博客，并去看看 R 那一期节目。
He has a ton of information there. If you're into R and you're a statistician especially. Or did you post up his comment? He posted it in a comment. Okay. Actually, we'll link to his comment from this show. Ooh, that's meta. Yeah, yeah, look out.
他在那里提供了大量信息。如果你对 R 感兴趣，尤其是如果你是统计学家的话。或者你发布了他的评论吗？他把它发在评论里了。好的。实际上，我们会在这期节目中链接到他的评论。噢，这太元（meta）了。是的，是的，留意一下。
That's like Inception or something. So, yeah, that's pretty cool. Definitely definitely check it out a lot of interesting stuff um another question we got this is from ash booth and he was saying uh basically what's the difference between kind of doing projects in school and uh working in industry um wow like where do we begin right there's no difference yeah right so i mean i'll say a couple of things um when you're most of the projects that you do in school are individual and so depending on the scope of the project if you're doing like a phd dissertation that takes four years um then you probably have some kind of source control and things like that. But even still, if you're developing by yourself or with one or two other people, you don't really have to document.
这就像《盗梦空间》之类的。所以，是的，这很酷。一定要去看看，有很多有趣的内容。我们收到的另一个问题来自 Ash Booth，他基本上是在问在学校做项目和在行业中工作有什么区别。哇，我们从哪里开始说起呢？其实没什么区别。是的，我是说，我想说几点。在学校里，你做的大多数项目都是个人的，所以根据项目的范围，如果你是在写博士论文，那需要四年时间，那么你可能会用到某种版本控制之类的东西。但即便如此，如果你是独自开发，或者和一两个其他人一起开发，你并不真的需要写文档。
You don't have to write a lot of tests because hopefully both of you or the three of you have all most of the same assumptions and and the code doesn't have to uh you know doesn't have to live for a very long time um and so definitely when you're working in industry you have to program very defensively because there's a lot of people on the team there's people on other teams who could break your code. And sometimes you write tests to make sure that other people can't break your code. So that's something to think about is, actually, someone put this really good in a really clever way. They said, if you're an industry, your code has to be peer reviewed. So presumably one or two people have to look at your code. So right off the bat, your code has been read three times more than it's been written.
你不需要写很多测试，因为希望你们两个人或三个人有大部分相同的假设，而且代码不需要存在很长时间。所以，在行业中工作时，你必须非常谨慎地编程，因为团队里有很多其他人，其他团队的人也可能会破坏你的代码。有时你编写测试是为了确保其他人不会破坏你的代码。所以这是值得思考的一点。实际上，有人说得非常巧妙。他们说，如果你在行业中，你的代码必须经过同行评审。所以大概有一两个人必须看你的代码。所以从一开始，你的代码被阅读的次数就比被编写的次数多三倍。
It's been written once and read three times, and that's before it even gets committed. And after that, it's just going to get read even more. And so coding in that environment is very different than than coding in school yep you pretty much summarized what i would say but yeah i think the big difference between school and industry is your projects tend to be very short-lived and you tend to almost never use existing code so you tend to almost never use existing code. So you tend to almost, what we call, I guess, greenfields, like code where you're starting from scratch versus an industry on the whole,
它被编写了一次，被阅读了三次，这甚至是在它被提交之前。在那之后，它会被阅读得更多。所以在那种环境下编码与在学校里编码非常不同。没错，你基本上总结了我想说的。但我认为学校和行业之间最大的区别在于，你的项目往往寿命很短，而且你几乎从不使用现有的代码。所以你往往几乎从不使用现有的代码。所以你往往几乎是在做我们所谓的“绿地项目”，也就是从零开始编写代码，而行业中总体上，
you're very rarely doing that. And even at some point, even if you started that way, after six months of working on something, it's no longer that way. And so you have a lot more maintenance, a lot more digging into code bases you're unfamiliar with or have been unmaintained uh and that's something that you don't really get experience with in school at least not in my schooling when they never gave us like a huge code base and said
你很少这样做。即使在某种程度上，即使你是那样开始的，在工作了六个月之后，情况就不再是那样了。所以你有更多的维护工作，更多地深入研究你不熟悉或未被维护的代码库，这是你在学校里真正无法获得经验的地方，至少在我的学校教育中，他们从没给我们一个巨大的代码库并说
here go fix something or add a new feature uh the closest we got was for our operating systems class we needed to add a feature to the bsd kernel oh that's cool yeah so we had to actually dig through and understand it at some level to be able to add it and that was pretty representative of the work you end up doing a lot also for me i didn't do graduate work so i got a master's degree but uh you know it's mostly just normal classes i didn't do any research and so for me the projects also tend to be much much smaller and i didn't work on research and so for me the projects also tend to be much much smaller and i didn't work on them eight hours a day for literally months years yep which can be very common at work yeah i mean you could work the same job for 10 years and you could literally be
“去修复一些东西或添加一个新功能”。我们最接近的一次是在操作系统课上，我们需要给 BSD 内核添加一个功能。哦，那很酷。是的，所以我们必须深入研究并在某种程度上理解它才能添加它，这非常能代表你最终要做的很多工作。另外，对我来说，我没有读研，所以我拿到了硕士学位，但你知道，这大多只是正常的课程，我没有做任何研究，所以对我来说，项目往往也小得多，而且我没有每天工作八小时，持续数月或数年，这在工作中非常普遍。是的，我的意思是，你可以在同一份工作上做 10 年，你可能真的
staring at the same code uh you know 40 hours a week for 10 years so i mean i mean hopefully you know it's you don't have to keep coming back to that code but but you'll be building on top of you know, 40 hours a week for 10 years. So, I mean, hopefully, you know, you don't have to keep coming back to that code, but you'll be building on top of that for years to come. Or if not you, someone else will, right? And then you said about peer review as a reason for writing it well or whatever. But, I mean, that's something else that's a really big difference. And many places have some form of peer review
每周 40 小时盯着同样的代码 10 年。所以，我的意思是，希望你不需要一直回到那段代码，但你会在那基础上构建。或者如果不是你，也会是别人，对吧？然后你提到了同行评审作为写好代码的原因之类的。但是，我的意思是，这是另一个非常大的区别。许多地方都有某种形式的同行评审，
or needing unit tests even. And this is something I never did other than theoretically in school. You may have to write unit tests for the unit test portion of some class, but it wasn't something we did for realsies. Yep. But in work, I do it for realsies. Yeah, yeah. I mean, like I said, if I don't write, I mean, this has happened to me
甚至需要单元测试。这是我除了在学校理论上学过之外从未做过的事情。你可能需要在某门课的单元测试部分编写单元测试，但这不是我们真正会做的事情。没错。但在工作中，我真的会做。是的，是的。我的意思是，就像我说的，如果我不写，我的意思是，这种情况发生在我身上，
where I don't write, I mean, this has happened to me where I don't write a unit test, and then another team that we're sharing the code base just breaks my code. And it's not that they're jerks or anything, it's just that they invalidated some of the assumptions I made, and without unit tests,
我不写单元测试，然后我们共享代码库的另一个团队就破坏了我的代码。并不是他们是混蛋什么的，只是他们否定了我做出的一些假设，而没有单元测试，
there was no way for them to know they did that, right? Cool. So so our last question Quang Nguyen asked basically what are our thoughts on programming competitions so Patrick and I have both
他们根本无法知道他们做了什么，对吧？酷。那么最后一个问题，Quang Nguyen 基本上问我们对编程竞赛有什么看法。所以 Patrick 和我都
done programming competitions one thing I can say it's so the situation is like this programming competition in terms of your time, right? I spent, I don't know, I spent maybe 2,000 or 3,000 hours working on programming competitions. Like either practicing, going to competitions, doing online competitions. I mean, I spent probably more than 3,000 hours.
参加过编程竞赛。有一点我可以肯定，编程竞赛在你的时间投入方面是这样的：我花了，我不知道，我可能花了 2000 或 3000 小时在编程竞赛上。比如练习、参加比赛、参加在线比赛。我的意思是，我可能花了超过 3000 小时。
If I had spent that much time doing work on open source projects or modifying the BSD kernel or something like that, it would have made me a better software engineer, right? But the coding competitions make you a better interviewee. And so both are, you know, you could argue about whether the interview process is broken because of that. A lot of people say that. And I don't disagree. I don't really know what we could do better.
如果我把那么多时间花在开源项目或修改 BSD 内核之类的事情上，那会让我成为一个更好的软件工程师，对吧？但编程竞赛让你成为一个更好的面试者。所以两者，你知道，你可以争论面试过程是否因此而崩溃。很多人这么说。我并不反对。我真的不知道我们能做得更好。
But the fact is, at least right now, you know, coding competitions will allow you to pass interviews that you would not have otherwise passed. But again, taking that same time and putting it into working with a big team, using source control and things like that would make you a better engineer. So yeah, use that information however it best suits you yeah i don't remember the exact question so i don't know if we're answering or not but on that topic it is uh true that i think there are two aspects to coding competitions one is doing stuff at speed so like making a stab or guess or you know doing the big order approximation big o approximation of a potential thing and understanding what the impact of that will be off the cuff thinking of an algorithm and implementing
但事实是，至少现在，你知道，编程竞赛会让你通过原本无法通过的面试。但同样，把同样的时间投入到与大团队合作、使用版本控制等事情上，会让你成为一个更好的工程师。所以，是的，根据最适合你的方式来利用这些信息。是的，我不记得确切的问题了，所以我不知道我们是否回答了，但关于这个话题，我认为编程竞赛有两个方面。一个是速度，比如做出判断或猜测，或者进行潜在事物的“大 O”近似，并了解其影响。即兴思考算法并实现
it sort of correct at least the first time like these things at speed are really great for working on a programming interview the second part is like the algorithms like actually learning various algorithms and tricks and data structures and understanding like you know when you're in grade school and they give you those word problems you have to learn that certain words mean addition certain word subtraction certain multiplication like learning those keywords like how to take a guess at what the data structure might be um I think those are two different parts, and the algorithms part has some usefulness outside, like learning what all these algorithms are and when to apply them and how to apply them.
它，至少第一次就正确。这些在速度上的东西对于编程面试真的很有帮助。第二部分是算法，比如真正学习各种算法、技巧和数据结构，并理解，你知道，当你在小学时，他们给你那些应用题，你必须学习某些词意味着加法，某些词意味着减法，某些词意味着乘法。学习这些关键词，比如如何猜测数据结构可能是什么。我认为这是两个不同的部分，算法部分在外部有一些用处，比如学习所有这些算法是什么，何时应用它们以及如何应用它们。
It's more generally useful long term. The coding at speed is really good up into a certain point, and then the diminishing curve kicks in really hard. So once you can do it fast and you're familiar with all the standard libraries of the language you choose to use and you can sort of get done in in the
从长远来看，它更有普遍的用处。快速编码在一定程度上真的很好，然后收益递减曲线就会非常明显地出现。所以一旦你能快速完成，并且熟悉你选择使用的语言的所有标准库，并且你可以在
time frames that the competitions normally have getting much faster will make you do better in the competition but not in real life right that makes sense even for a programming interview i don't think it really matters you don't have to have super speed you just have to be quick but not fast yeah so maybe so maybe the best advice here is especially for people in college and and things like that is is uh you know to be like decent at you know top coder and these other sites but you don't have to be great maybe that's yeah i would think like the way i would view it so so to use Topcoder specifically, is I think it's valuable to get to the point where, be honest with yourself,
比赛通常有的时间框架内完成，变得更快会让你在比赛中表现更好，但在现实生活中不会，对吧？这很有道理。即使对于编程面试，我不认为这真的重要，你不需要有超人的速度，你只需要敏捷，而不是极快。是的，所以也许这里最好的建议是，特别是对于大学生和类似的人，是，你知道，在 TopCoder 和这些其他网站上表现得体面，但你不必非常出色。也许是这样。是的，我会这样看，专门使用 TopCoder，我认为达到这一点是有价值的，对自己诚实，
like on the easier, there's like an easier mode and a harder mode or an easier level and a hard level. It's like on the easier level, you really should be solving the easy one, correct the first time, the easiest question. The middle question,
比如在较简单的模式和较难的模式，或者较简单的级别和较难的级别。在较简单的级别上，你真的应该第一次就解决那个简单的题目，最简单的那个问题。中间的问题，
you should be getting right in the time frame and you should often get the hard one right uh and all of that within the time frame that they set for you so you can do like practice competition or whatever yeah but it isn't important you get it the absolute fastest well i don't know about you but i i so for me to do one of the hard ones it it takes me about a full day on the easy one oh you're talking about the division the easy division yeah yeah oh yeah right okay that makes sense yeah sorry yeah so i think the hard division gets into competitiveness so you should be able to do the easy one but the easy one on the hard one is typically oh that's so confusing the level two
你应该在时间框架内做对，而且你应该经常做对那个难题。所有这些都在他们为你设定的时间框架内，所以你可以进行练习比赛之类的。是的，但你以绝对最快的速度完成并不重要。好吧，我不知道你怎么样，但对我来说，要做其中一个难题，它需要我大约一整天的时间。在简单的那个上？哦，你在说分级，简单的分级。是的，是的。哦，是的，没错，好的，这很有道理。是的，抱歉。所以，我认为困难的分级进入了竞争性，所以你应该能够做简单的那个，但在困难分级上的简单那个通常是……哦，这太令人困惑了。二级
easy one is typically the level one medium one yeah just to recap so there's two divisions in top coder there's division two which is uh think of it like the minor leagues and division two has has it's fine division two has easy medium and hard and they typically although not always but they typically take the hard division two problem and make it the easy division one problem and then now there's another medium and hard in division one i don't know too much about division two but in division one the i've never gotten a hard problem right in the 90 minutes that they give you um and i've only gotten hard problems right I mean the smallest the lowest time has been something like five hours
简单那个通常是一级的中等那个。是的，总结一下，TopCoder 有两个分级，一个是 Division 2，把它想象成小联盟，Division 2 有简单、中等和困难，它们通常——虽然不总是，但通常——会把 Division 2 的困难问题作为 Division 1 的简单问题，然后现在 Division 1 还有另一个中等和困难。我对 Division 2 不太了解，但在 Division 1 中，我在他们给的 90 分钟内从来没有做对过难题，而且我只做对过难题……我的意思是，最短、最低的时间大约是 5 小时
for me to get a hard problem right so there's definitely a no but I'm saying I don't I would go further so but you actually did so I did competition too but you did a lot more than me but I that's what I was saying like I don't actually think division one is necessary at all I think you need to be able to do
我才能做对一个难题。所以肯定有一个……不，但我说的是，我会走得更远。但你确实做了……所以我确实也参加了比赛，但你比我做得多得多。但我就是这么说的，我不认为 Division 1 是必要的。我认为你需要能够做
division two in the time frames they give you as like a, are you doing well enough? Yep. I think that's sufficient. We talked about this in our earlier episode, but one of the things, kind of going back against what I said earlier, playing, I guess, devil's advocate against myself.
Division 2 在他们给你的时间框架内，作为一种“你做得够好吗？”的衡量。没错。我认为这就足够了。我们在之前的节目中谈过这个，但其中一件事，有点违背我之前所说的，扮演魔鬼代言人反对我自己。
One of the things that pro-game competitions do give you is an ability to look at problems and kind of eyeball how difficult they are yeah that's what I was trying to say maybe I said it yeah yeah like like you see like like like an approximate
编程竞赛给你的其中一件事是能够观察问题并大致估算它们有多难。是的，这就是我试图说的，也许我说了。是的，就像你看到一个近似值，
estimate like just a swag at it like yeah this is really easy like a top coder it's explicit like you just see this problem and it might like there's not true because sometimes like the hard one and the medium one are similar in difficulty oh that's true that's and it's better to do the hard one first yeah well in div 2 that might be a div 1 the hard one's almost always impossible like to do in 90 minutes it's like
就像一个粗略的估计，就像“是的，这很容易”。像 TopCoder，它是明确的，你只是看到这个问题，它可能……这不是真的，因为有时难题和中等题在难度上是相似的。哦，那是真的。而且最好先做难题。是的，好吧，在 Div 2 中，那可能是一个 Div 1 的问题。难题几乎总是不可能在 90 分钟内完成的。它就像
always some math or statistics trick and you've either memorized all the tricks the people i know who get the hard ones right um are people who have just memorized a ton of number theory tricks and theorems and they just see it and they know okay that's this theorem let me start coding and for the rest of us plebeians, it's like impossible. But yeah, to Patrick's point, you can look at a certain problem and say, your boss can come to you and say, okay, we need to get this access time down to 10 milliseconds.
总是某种数学或统计学技巧，你要么背下了所有的技巧——我认识的那些做对难题的人，是那些背下了大量数论技巧和定理的人，他们一看就知道“好的，那是这个定理，让我开始编码”。而对于我们这些平民来说，这简直是不可能的。但是的，回到 Patrick 的观点，你可以看一个特定的问题并说，你的老板可以来找你说，“好的，我们需要把这个访问时间降到 10 毫秒。
Is there some kind of caching or something we could do? And you can look at that and say, yeah, that's doable. Or that's going's doable or you know that's going to take years and and it might not even happen right so um like uh like we could like write some function to do that or there's a bunch of heuristics we need to you know do data science and and and figure out if we can you know uh if there's some trick in the data or something right so so yeah anyways that's sort of long-winded answer the answer is yes they help but uh only to a point yeah only to a certain extent but that's true of most things in life that's right it's it's uh it's actually an uncanny
有没有什么缓存之类的我们可以做？”你可以看着它说，“是的，那是可行的。”或者“那需要几年时间，甚至可能根本不会发生。”对吧？所以，比如我们可以写一些函数来做那个，或者有一堆启发式方法我们需要做数据科学，并弄清楚我们是否可以……如果数据中有什么技巧之类的。所以，是的，无论如何，这是一个冗长的回答。答案是肯定的，它们有帮助，但只到一定程度。是的，只到一定程度。但这在生活中大多数事情上都是如此。没错，这实际上是一个恐怖谷，
valley if you are in the top maybe 50 people in the world on top coder then now you're like kind of pseudo famous and that's great. If you're anywhere between there and the bottom 50 percentile, it doesn't matter. And then anything from there to maybe the bottom 1 percentile is better than nothing. So, anyways,
如果你在 TopCoder 上处于世界前 50 名，那么你现在有点伪名人了，那很好。如果你在那个和后 50% 之间，那没关系。然后从那里到后 1% 左右比什么都没有要好。所以，无论如何，
your mileage may vary. Although I found that a lot of the nasty tricks I learned in coding competition helped me to be really fast at debugging code on the fly like just hacking print statements in or whatever is necessary in in a loop to just get something out and you learn like how to make the compiler be quiet and just like how do i force with the minimal lines of code to get it to do what i want yeah that's a good point i think that uh and you would never code that way like i would never check
因人而异。虽然我发现我在编程竞赛中学到的很多讨厌的技巧帮助我非常快速地调试代码，比如在循环中插入打印语句或任何必要的东西来获取一些输出，你学会了如何让编译器安静，以及如何强制用最少的代码行来让它做我想做的事。是的，这是一个很好的观点。我认为……而且你永远不会那样写代码，我永远不会那样提交
in code that way but when i'm writing test code or debugging something like i people always look at me i'm like what you can do that it's like sure you can cast this thing that way you shouldn't but you can yep yep yeah i think that uh there's it's sort of like those people who work who actually worked in a newspaper who have to produce a newspaper every week they just have a ton of tricks that if you just wanted to write an article yourself like they could just they could write it 10 times faster and it's because they were put in a position where they had to write an article in 30 minutes and they just figured out how to get it done and it's usually things that go against your intuition
代码，但当我编写测试代码或调试某些东西时，人们总是看着我，我说“什么？你可以那样做？”就像“当然，你可以那样转换这个东西，你不应该这样做，但你可以。”没错，没错。是的，我认为这有点像那些在报社工作的人，他们必须每周制作一份报纸，他们只是有很多技巧，如果你想自己写一篇文章，他们可以写得快 10 倍，这是因为他们被置于必须在 30 分钟内写出一篇文章的位置，他们只是弄清楚了如何完成它，而且通常是那些违背你直觉的事情，
that you would think are kind of bad but they really work and it's the same with coding there's just like hideous things they that never make it into the final product but are stepping stones to being very efficient yeah all right cool time for the news news so first news article is something we talked about on uh last month last but uh but uh it's uh this is a very this article goes into a lot of detail on it uh The title of the article is Amazon's $23.7 million book about flies. Basically, this guy is, I think, a biologist or an ethnomologist. I know he studies insects. He wanted to buy this book. The book typically retails for around forty dollars and these two sites they each had it for three hundred dollars and he said that's kind of ridiculous and uh he went to send the link to somebody else and by the time he sent it to them the book was worth on like four hundred
你可能会认为它们有点糟糕，但它们确实有效。编码也是一样，有一些丑陋的东西永远不会进入最终产品，但却是提高效率的垫脚石。是的，好的，酷。新闻时间。第一篇新闻文章是我们上个月谈论过的……但这篇报道非常详细。文章标题是《亚马逊关于苍蝇的 2370 万美元的书》。基本上，这个人，我想是一位生物学家或昆虫学家。我知道他研究昆虫。他想买这本书。这本书通常零售价约为 40 美元，而这两个网站每个网站的售价都是 300 美元，他说这有点荒谬。他去把链接发给别人，当他发给他们时，这本书的价格已经涨到了大约 400
dollars and then that really kind of got his attention so sure enough uh after a month or so the book was worth 24 you know 23 and a half million dollars and it's just a 40 book and and at the very end it ends up being worth like 40 again but this is all about sort of he actually deconstructed um the algorithm they were increasing by a set factor right so like one was under one was over like one was trying to be the cheapest by some margin but only a little margin and the other was trying to be slightly more expensive than that one yep yeah and so it just had this race condition well it's race conditions not the right word but yeah it was like an unstable equilibrium so so yeah one of them increases the price 20 the other one increases the price 19 and then the first one you know sees that increase and increases the price 20
美元，然后这真的引起了他的注意。所以果然，一个月左右后，这本书价值 2400 万美元，而它只是一本 40 美元的书。最后它又变回了 40 美元左右。但这完全是关于他实际上解构了他们的算法，他们按设定的系数增加价格，对吧？比如一个高一点，一个低一点，一个试图以某种幅度成为最便宜的，但只是一点点幅度，而另一个试图比那个稍微贵一点。没错。所以它只是有这种竞争条件……好吧，“竞争条件”不是正确的词，但是的，它就像一个不稳定的平衡。所以，是的，其中一个把价格提高了 20%，另一个提高了 19%，然后第一个看到那个增长，又提高了 20%，
it just keeps going until a book you know 40 book is worth 20 million yeah and eventually someone realizes it's crazy and just manually resets the price lower yeah yeah they must have humans in the loop that look at you know everything that's retailing for more than 20 million and do something manual i mean so yeah i was trying to think if there's a way to exploit this behavior but i don't think they're i mean you could make people's prices be driven up but it doesn't really matter they just won't sell the book well i i thought about this right what if you what if you lie to amazon and say you have the book for a dollar wouldn't that make them lower the price yes except then if someone buys
它就这样一直持续下去，直到一本 40 美元的书价值 2000 万美元。是的，最终有人意识到这很疯狂，并手动将价格重置得更低。是的，他们肯定有人在循环中查看所有零售价超过 2000 万美元的东西，并进行手动操作。我的意思是，是的，我一直在想是否有办法利用这种行为，但我不认为……我的意思是，你可以让人们的价格被推高，但这并不重要，他们只是卖不掉那本书。好吧，我想过这个，对吧？如果你对亚马逊撒谎说你有一本关于苍蝇的书，售价一美元，那不会让他们降低价格吗？是的，除非在那段时间有人买了
it in that time period that's right yeah you have to that's the problem right you have to say i have the book for a dollar hoping that there aren't that many people buying books on flies. But then maybe they would buy your book. Now you're kind of in trouble. Like the people who are selling the $23 million book would buy your book. And there might be people out there, which I would not be surprised, but I've never heard of it, who are like watching for, like they historically track books with enough, like this one's probably rare enough where they don't, but books with enough volume or just anything with enough volume and they look for used price
它。没错，是的，你必须……这就是问题所在，对吧？你必须说我有一本关于苍蝇的书，售价一美元，希望买书的人没那么多。但后来也许他们会买你的书。现在你有点麻烦了。比如那些卖 2300 万美元书的人会买你的书。而且外面可能有人，我不会感到惊讶，但我从未听说过，他们像是在寻找……比如这本书可能足够稀有，他们不会，但有足够销量的书，或者任何有足够销量的东西，他们寻找二手价格
discrepancies and if it's a big enough discrepancy they buy it right and then you know essentially try to sell it back like there are people on ebay that do that search for misspellings of words yep it's like the or certain like old objects that people don't know what they are so they say like oh i found this weird bottle opener and it turns out it's not a bottle opener it's an antique surgical instrument right but if you search like weird iron bottle opener you find these really rare collectible you know yeah yeah totally so so yeah i think the answer is yes you could take advantage of it but you will probably get in trouble and get yourself in a sticky situation so um especially if it's about flies so don't buy books about flies that's the
差异，如果差异足够大，他们就买下它，然后本质上试图把它卖回去。eBay 上有人这样做，搜索单词的拼写错误。没错，就像某些旧物品，人们不知道它们是什么，所以他们说“哦，我发现了这个奇怪的开瓶器”，结果发现它不是开瓶器，它是古董手术器械。对吧？但如果你搜索“奇怪的铁开瓶器”，你会发现这些非常稀有的收藏品。是的，是的，完全正确。所以，是的，我认为答案是肯定的，你可以利用它，但你可能会惹上麻烦，让自己陷入困境。所以，特别是如果它是关于苍蝇的。所以不要买关于苍蝇的书，这就是那个故事的
moral of that story right exactly uh so the next article is a regex1.com which is an interactive tutorial for learning regular expressions online. So Jason actually found this link, this article, and I find that this is going to be awesome. I am going to try this tomorrow because I stink at regular expressions. I'm a big fan of the quote, what is it? If there's a problem and you solve it with regular expressions, congratulations, you now have two problems. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, so this is actually a user, a listener request. So
寓意。没错，正是如此。那么下一篇文章是 regex1.com，这是一个在线学习正则表达式的交互式教程。Jason 实际上找到了这个链接，这篇文章，我觉得这太棒了。我明天要试试这个，因为我的正则表达式很烂。我很喜欢那句名言，是什么来着？“如果你有一个问题，你用正则表达式解决了它，恭喜你，你现在有两个问题了。”是的，完全正确。是的，所以这实际上是一个用户的请求。所以
Nicholas Bailey sent an email saying, hey, can you talk about regular expressions? And so this is for you, Nicholas. We're talking about regular expressions. I'm also in the same boat as Patrick here, where every time I need to use regex, I always have to fudge my way through it online
Nicholas Bailey 发了一封邮件说：“嘿，你们能谈谈正则表达式吗？”所以这是给你的，Nicholas。我们在谈论正则表达式。我也和 Patrick 在同一条船上，每次我需要使用正则表达式时，我总是不得不在线上胡乱拼凑，
and I get it wrong nine times and then on the tenth time it finally does what I want and it's one of these things like I think it'd be good for me to just bite the bullet and like dive into regex for a week and then get to the
我九次都弄错了，然后在第十次它终于做了我想要的事。这是其中一件事，我想如果我能咬紧牙关，花一周时间深入研究正则表达式，然后达到
point where I could just write the regex correct the first time so yeah I'll also be trying this website. Yeah, the next one is interesting. Things I was unprepared for as a lead developer. So, you know, most teams, the way they're structured is you have your team and you have a manager who typically manages maybe 10 or 15 people, and then you have a tech lead who is in charge of maybe two or three people. And the tech lead typically also writes code himself versus the manager typically just manages. So this person moved from an established company to a startup um at the startup he was
我可以第一次就写出正确的正则表达式的程度，那对我来说会很好。所以，是的，我也会试试这个网站。是的，下一篇很有趣。《作为首席开发人员我未准备好的事情》。所以，你知道，大多数团队的结构是你有你的团队，你有一个通常管理 10 或 15 人的经理，然后你有一个负责两三个人左右的技术主管。技术主管通常也自己写代码，而经理通常只是管理。所以这个人从一家成熟的公司跳槽到了一家初创公司。在初创公司，他是
lead developer and uh this is just sort of like a a uh a monologue um sort of like a diary about his experiences as lead developer uh specifically things he didn't expect and i thought this was really fascinating um so it's definitely worth reading I won't spoil it but no go ahead well yeah I'll spoil it the one that really stuck out to me was
首席开发人员，这只是一种……一种独白，一种关于他作为首席开发人员经历的日记，特别是他没预料到的事情。我觉得这非常迷人，所以绝对值得一读。我不会剧透，但……不，请继续。好吧，是的，我会剧透。真正让我印象深刻的是
as lead developer you obviously you're in the trenches and so you spend a lot of time with the developers but at the same time you're given the trenches and so you spend a lot of time with the developers um but at the same time you're given sort of a more high level vision and so in his case you know he's at the startup and so he's learning things like you know if this product isn't successful or if it has severe bugs then they're going to shut down the startup and so the people that he's managing like all of them
作为首席开发人员，你显然身处一线，所以你花了很多时间与开发人员在一起，但同时你被赋予了……你身处一线，所以你花了很多时间与开发人员在一起，但同时你被赋予了某种更高层次的愿景。所以在他那种情况下，你知道，他在初创公司，所以他正在学习一些事情，比如“如果这个产品不成功，或者如果有严重的漏洞，那么他们就会关闭初创公司”，所以他管理的那些人，他们所有人
are just going to be out of a job and then one of his employees comes to him and asks him if he can you know learn ruby on the side and and he wants to do that but in the back of mind he's thinking like dude our startup's going to die in a month if we don't get this done and you're asking me if you want to learn ruby on the side and but you know again his job as the lead developer is to insulate his team so they don't have to worry about the startup going under or whatever right so so so part of that is is is answering that question rationally um you know pretending like he doesn't feel all this other gravity and then saying you know yeah go ahead and learn ruby it's not a big impact on the team or no you can't learn ruby right now
都将失业。然后他的一名员工来找他，问他是否可以……你知道，在业余时间学习 Ruby，他想这样做，但在他的脑海深处，他在想：“伙计，如果我们不完成这个，我们的初创公司一个月内就会倒闭，而你却在问我是否想在业余时间学习 Ruby。”但你知道，再次强调，他作为首席开发人员的工作是保护他的团队，这样他们就不必担心初创公司倒闭之类的。所以，所以，所以其中的一部分是理性地回答那个问题，你知道，假装他没有感受到所有这些其他的压力，然后说：“你知道，是的，去学习 Ruby 吧，这对团队影响不大。”或者“不，你现在不能学习 Ruby。”
not you know what are you doing the whole company's gonna die right so so i think that's sort of in a nutshell is a lot of his issues is sort of walking this sort of double double life leading this double life so it's definitely interesting. I highly recommend reading it. So the next article I have is actually not that important. It sounds weird. Anyways, it's about the JetBrains developers of IDEs, and they changed their licensing, or originally changed their licensing and changed it back,
“你到底在做什么？整个公司都要倒闭了。”所以，所以我认为这简而言之就是他的很多问题，有点像过着这种双重生活，领导着这种双重生活。所以这绝对很有趣。我强烈推荐阅读它。所以我有的下一篇文章实际上并不那么重要。这听起来很奇怪。无论如何，它是关于 JetBrains，IDE 的开发者，他们改变了他们的许可，或者最初改变了他们的许可，然后又改了回来，
and they changed their mind. Anyways, I want to use this as an opportunity to rant about why everything is going to web-based subscription licenses so jet brains originally announced this so before you could buy you know a license to the software for a flat fee then they were going to now you need to pay a monthly subscription in order to have your software and if you stop paying it you don't own it anymore and the companies tend to think this is good for you as an individual but in all the cases i tend to look at it it seems bad to me so the problem is they're collecting subscription fees which is great and as far as that like if i stop use if i only want to use it once in a while i can pay a
他们改变了主意。无论如何，我想利用这个机会抱怨一下为什么一切都在转向基于网络的订阅许可。所以 JetBrains 最初宣布了这个……所以以前你可以购买软件的许可，支付一次性费用，然后他们现在要……你需要支付月度订阅费才能拥有你的软件，如果你停止支付，你就不再拥有它了。公司倾向于认为这对你个人有好处，但在我倾向于观察的所有案例中，它对我来说似乎很糟糕。所以问题是他们正在收取订阅费，这很好，就那种……如果我停止使用，如果我只是偶尔想用一下，我可以支付一个
subscription fee and then stop using it and stop paying which is nice and it sounds cheaper up front but then the fact that like long term i don't own it and if i stop paying i lose it uh is it's not great for me and also if there's new versions of a software released the company needs to and they don't constantly improve the version I have because they're not really incentivized to. So that's kind of bad. But they're really incentivized to make it awesome for the next one or I don't pay again.
订阅费，然后停止使用并停止支付，这很好，听起来前期更便宜。但后来事实是，长期来看我不拥有它，如果我停止支付，我就失去了它，这对我来说并不好。而且如果发布了软件的新版本，公司需要……而且他们并没有不断改进我拥有的版本，因为他们并没有真正被激励这样做。所以这有点糟糕。但他们确实被激励去让下一个版本变得很棒，否则我就不会再次付费了。
And when you go to a subscription model, it's a little loosey-goosey to me as far as why would they continue to give updates at an awesome rate. Because you're paying to use it you really like it you need to keep using it and it's not like if you stop paying you just stop getting new features you lose access right yeah i mean so a couple of things about this one uh bit torrent sync which i had as a tool to show a while ago they had a subscription model for the pro version and i never bought it because um there's something about subscription models.
当你转向订阅模式时，对我来说有点松散，至于为什么他们会继续以惊人的速度提供更新。因为你付费使用它，你真的很喜欢它，你需要继续使用它，而且不像如果你停止付费，你只是停止获得新功能，你失去了访问权限。对吧？是的，我的意思是，关于这个有几点。BitTorrent Sync，我之前把它作为一个工具展示过，他们对专业版有订阅模式，我从来没买过，因为……关于订阅模式有一些东西。
It's sort of like I think it's a psychological thing, but you just actually I'll get to that later because there's a whole separate rant about that. But they switched to a one time purchase model. I think it's just 50 bucks now and i bought it immediately so i mean they went from not getting anything from me and me doing everything i could to use the free version and get the most out of it to like them just immediately getting 50 bucks um i see the other side of it though which is they're basically never going to get money from me again so so that who cares because like for bit torn sync they don't have a maintenance cost so why should they continue to get money from you um that's that's true yeah so so presumably
这有点像……我认为这是一种心理上的东西，但你只是……实际上，我稍后会谈到这一点，因为关于那个有一个单独的抱怨。但他们切换到了一次性购买模式。我想现在只要 50 美元，我立刻就买了。所以，我的意思是，他们从我这里什么都没得到，而我尽我所能使用免费版本并充分利用它，变成了他们立刻得到了 50 美元。不过我看到了它的另一面，那就是他们基本上再也不会从我这里得到钱了。所以，谁在乎呢？因为像 BitTorrent Sync，他们没有维护成本，所以他们为什么要继续从你那里得到钱？那是真的。是的，所以，所以大概
now they should use all of these 50 investments to build another product that they're not who cares well they have to keep their company going right sure i mean if they want to right but they could just make a product and be done like that's okay too um yeah maybe i mean you would like them to keep it updated right and they want to continue to make sales it probably is worth it to them to keep it maintained because then people will keep buying the existing version at least right but what i'm saying is like for people that run a service or server and there's cost to it i understand right like you have costs to keep this thing up i have to pay you because you have to pay for me to continue using it but for things
现在他们应该利用所有这些 50 美元的投资来构建另一个产品，他们……谁在乎呢？好吧，他们必须维持他们的公司运转，对吧？当然，我的意思是，如果他们想的话。但他们可以只是做一个产品然后就完成了，那也可以。是的，也许。我的意思是，你希望他们保持更新，对吧？而且他们想继续销售，保持维护可能对他们来说是值得的，因为那样人们至少会继续购买现有版本。但我说的是，对于那些运行服务或服务器的人来说，有成本，我理解。对吧？就像你有成本来维持这个东西，我必须付钱给你，因为你必须支付费用让我继续使用它。但对于像
like photoshop or an ide right it's i'm using all my own resources. All you're doing is keeping a licensed server up. Yeah. I mean, you're, you, you have to assume that they are spending a lot of money, like improving the product. If they don't do that, then you're absolutely right. It's just, you're throwing money away, but presumably you're, you know, $10 a month or whatever it is goes to allows them to hire some engineers to work on it um but i guess costs aren't typically that drastically different right like in the short term theoretically right because the if i pay you a hundred dollars once and i buy your new software every year or i pay you ten dollars every month like it's roughly equivalent.
Photoshop 或 IDE 这样的东西，我正在使用我自己的所有资源。你所做的只是维持一个许可服务器。是的。我的意思是，你必须假设他们花了很多钱，比如改进产品。如果他们不这样做，那么你是绝对正确的。这只是……你在浪费钱，但大概你……你知道，每月 10 美元或无论多少钱，都用于允许他们雇佣一些工程师来处理它。但我猜成本通常不会那么剧烈地不同，对吧？就像短期内理论上一样，因为如果我付给你 100 美元一次，我每年买你的新软件，或者我每月付给你 10 美元，这大致是等价的。
Yeah, that's true. That's true. The big difference for me is just, like, if I stop paying, I can't keep... If I'm happy with what I have for now, I can't just continue to use it without paying. Right. But to be fair, there's a barrier of entry. Like, if I try JetBrains and I don't like it,
是的，那是真的。那是真的。对我来说，最大的区别只是，如果我停止支付，我就不能继续……如果我对目前拥有的东西感到满意，我就不能在不付费的情况下继续使用它。对吧？但公平地说，有一个进入门槛。比如，如果我尝试 JetBrains 而我不喜欢它，
I can cancel, and I only paid one month. No, I understand. Yeah, if I have to pay $300, then I might just never try it. So yeah, they have to do some kind of shareware version or something. But there's a lot of, yeah, like 30-day trials, right? Yeah, right. That's a common thing.
我可以取消，我只付了一个月。不，我明白。是的，如果我必须支付 300 美元，那么我可能永远不会尝试它。所以，是的，他们必须做某种共享软件版本之类的。但有很多，是的，比如 30 天试用，对吧？是的，没错。那是一件常见的事情。
Yeah, that's true. Yeah, I mean, I'm definitely with you. I mean, anything that's been a subscription, I'm trying to think of anything. I can't honestly think of anything other than Netflix and Hulu that are and those don't even really count those are more like utilities yeah video and music I do but I don't really I'd rather I'm not sure if that's a great idea for me or not like I haven't I'm not fully sold that I feel like
是的，那是真的。是的，我的意思是，我绝对和你在一起。我的意思是，任何订阅的东西，我都在想任何东西。我真的想不出除了 Netflix 和 Hulu 之外的任何东西，而且那些甚至不算，那些更像是公用事业。是的，视频和音乐我确实订阅了，但我真的……我不确定这对我是不是个好主意，或者不是。就像我还没有……我没有完全被说服，我觉得
those are those are basically like utilities I mean I mean the difference between you know say Spotify and JetBrains is thatify is you know presumably putting out new content all the time and you're paying for the content well man they're not responsible for getting the content right like they're they have to sign but like the artists and stuff are making the content they just have to make sure to keep doing the deals right right and the deals cost money hence the hence the subscription like otherwise the point is like if i like if i really like this ide and i pay every and again this this specific idea is really kind of irrelevant i don't use it so maybe it's a bad thing to pick no i think it's good it's a good discussion is
那些基本上就像是公用事业，我的意思是，你知道，Spotify 和 JetBrains 之间的区别在于，Spotify 可能一直在发布新内容，而你是在为内容付费，但他们并不负责内容的制作，对吧？他们必须签署协议，但艺术家们在创作内容，他们只需要确保继续达成交易，对吧？而且交易需要花钱，所以才会有订阅费，否则重点是，如果我真的很喜欢这个 IDE，并且我每次都付费，再说一次，这个特定的 IDE 其实无关紧要，我不用它，所以选它可能不太好，不，我觉得这很好，这是一个很好的讨论。
that like if i really like where it's at and i don't just particularly want to pay for it right now like i don't need to upgrade i'm happy where it is and i just want to keep at and I don't just particularly want to pay for it right now like I don't need to upgrade I'm happy where it is and I just want to keep using it I don't have that option that's true yep that's true so like this is what I do for some Adobe products like I have Lightroom for my pictures but I'm not on the newest one I'm on like several versions
就像如果我真的很喜欢它现在的样子，而我现在不想特别为它付费，因为我不需要升级，我对它现在的状态很满意，我只想继续使用它，但我没有那个选择，那是真的，是的，那是真的，所以这就是我对待某些 Adobe 产品的方式，比如我有 Lightroom 来处理我的照片，但我用的不是最新的版本，我用的是几个版本之前的。
ago yeah I have the same thing with Illustrator like I'm happy with what it is right now like I don't need to upgrade yeah the whole adobe creative cloud thing i just can't deal with it like like the idea that like because this is a problem is i don't use illustrator often enough to make the monthly fee worth it like for for a product that i'm going to use once every four months you know i can't justify spending fifty dollars a month it's ridiculous but you could
是的，我在 Illustrator 上也有同样的情况，我对它现在的样子很满意，不需要升级，是的，整个 Adobe Creative Cloud 的事情，我真的无法接受，因为问题在于我使用 Illustrator 的频率不足以让每月的费用变得物有所值，对于一个我每四个月才用一次的产品，你知道，我无法证明每月花五十美元是合理的，这太荒谬了，但你可以
justify buying i think it cost me like a hundred dollars when i bought it right yeah but i've used it for two or three years yep yeah i bought illustrator before the whole cloud thing for i think it was like two hundred dollars and the same thing i used it for i've been using it for i don't know six years or something anyways anyway so uh the other thing last thing about that is uh you know people think that so this is about the subscription thing people think oh if i get this ide i'm gonna be paying for it forever um this goes to like a psychological thing people generally feel like they don't change i don't know if you read this article but people feel like they change way less than they actually do so they did this study they surveyed a bunch of 20 year olds
证明购买是合理的，我想我买的时候大概花了一百美元，对吧，是的，但我已经用了两三年了，是的，我在整个云服务出现之前就买了 Illustrator，我想大概是两百美元，同样的情况，我已经用了，我不知道，六年左右了，总之，关于这个的最后一件事是，你知道人们认为，所以这是关于订阅的事情，人们认为，哦，如果我买了这套 IDE，我就得永远为它付费，这涉及到一种心理，人们通常觉得他们不会改变，我不知道你有没有读过那篇文章，但人们觉得他们改变的程度远比实际要小，所以他们做了这项研究，调查了一群 20 岁的人
and said 10 years from now will you like the same style of music that you do now and the majority said yes and then they interviewed a bunch of 30-year-olds and said, do you still like the same music you did 10 years ago? And almost 90% of them said no. And then they thought, okay, well, maybe 20-year-olds just don't get it, right? So they did the same thing to 30-year-olds, 40-year-olds, 50-year-olds. And every single generation did the same thing. Every generation felt like even 60-year- olds felt like they wouldn't change when they were 70 and they changed and so with respect to subscriptions yeah i always feel like i'm going
并问他们，10 年后你还会喜欢现在这种风格的音乐吗？大多数人说会，然后他们采访了一群 30 岁的人，问他们，你还喜欢 10 年前喜欢的音乐吗？几乎 90% 的人说不。然后他们想，好吧，也许 20 岁的人只是不明白，对吧？所以他们对 30 岁、40 岁、50 岁的人做了同样的事情。每一代人都做了同样的事情。每一代人都觉得，即使是 60 岁的人也觉得他们在 70 岁时不会改变，但他们确实改变了，所以关于订阅，是的，我总是觉得我会
to be paying for this forever like bit torrent sync i feel like i'm gonna be paying you know 10 a month for the next 20 years or maybe not that extreme but But when really, like, so, like, what you actually pay versus what you get for subscription versus one-time fee, your brain doesn't process that correctly. And so, that makes subscriptions an even worse idea. Anyway, so, time for book of the show. Book of the show. So, my book of the show book of the show so my book of the show is a kickstarter um project so it hasn't materialized yet although i'm eagerly waiting it it's a remake of can we still join or are you just teasing us with something we can't join a good question so i asked the person running the project if people could still join because the project has already been funded and it's over from that perspective. But he said yes. He said just email me or message him through Kickstarter and give him some information and PayPal him 50 bucks and you can join so so basically even though you can't join through kickstarter
永远为这个付费，比如 BitTorrent Sync，我觉得我未来 20 年每个月都要付 10 美元，或者可能没那么极端，但实际上，你付出的钱和你通过订阅得到的价值与一次性费用相比，你的大脑处理得并不准确。所以，这让订阅成了一个更糟糕的主意。总之，现在是本期推荐书目的时间。本期推荐书目。所以，我的本期推荐书目是一个 Kickstarter 项目，所以它还没有实现，尽管我热切地等待着，它是对……我们还能加入吗，还是你只是在用我们无法加入的东西逗我们？好问题，所以我问了负责这个项目的人，人们是否还能加入，因为该项目已经筹集到资金，从那个角度来看已经结束了。但他说是的。他说只要给我发电子邮件或通过 Kickstarter 给发消息，提供一些信息，然后通过 PayPal 给 50 美元，你就可以加入，所以基本上即使你不能通过 Kickstarter 加入
you can still uh get the book um so the book is uh paranoia rpg it's specifically it's a remake so paranoia rpg is a book that came out a long time ago um it's a game book uh so it's kind of like dungeons and dragons these other ones um but this one, the catch is you're sitting around at this table playing with these other people. One of the person is a game master, so just like D&D. But each person has a secret mission. And the secret mission is always destructive. Like my secret mission might be get Patrick killed as many times as possible. Patrick's secret mission might be like fail this
你仍然可以得到这本书，这本书是《Paranoia RPG》，具体来说，它是一个重制版，所以《Paranoia RPG》是一本很久以前出版的书，它是一本游戏书，所以它有点像《龙与地下城》和其他那些游戏，但这一本的特别之处在于，你坐在桌子旁和其他人一起玩。其中一个人是游戏主持人，就像《龙与地下城》一样。但每个人都有一个秘密任务。而且秘密任务总是具有破坏性的。比如我的秘密任务可能是让帕特里克尽可能多地被杀掉。帕特里克的秘密任务可能是搞砸任务的这一部分。所以游戏的运作方式不是掷骰子，好吧，你也掷骰子，但除了掷骰子之外，每次你采取行动时，每个人都会递给游戏主持人一张卡片。大多数卡片是空的。所以你开始时手里有一把卡片。也许其中 20 张是空的，但你有三张写着“自动失败”，无论你现在正在做什么行动。你有三张写着“自动成功”。
one part of the mission. And so the way the game works is instead of rolling dice, well, you roll dice too, but in addition to rolling dice, every time you take an action, everybody passes a card to the game master. And most of the cards are empty. So you start off with a handful of cards. Maybe 20 of them are empty, but you have three of them that say automatically fail, whatever action you're doing right now. And you have three of them that say automatically succeed.
所以如果帕特里克试图打开护盾发生器，而我的任务是让帕特里克尽可能多地被杀掉，而且他正受到敌人的火力攻击，那么我会递出我的“帕特里克这次掷骰失败”卡片，但因为每个人都在递卡片，帕特里克不知道我做了什么，他不知道是我做的，至少不是马上知道，所以这就是整个重点，但是有一件事是，如果
And so if Patrick is trying to turn on the shield generator, and my mission is get Patrick killed as many times as possible and he's under fire from enemies then i will pass my you know patrick fails this roll card but because everyone's passing a card patrick doesn't know what i did he doesn't know it was me who did that at least not right away and so um so that's kind of the whole point is like but one thing is like if
你搞砸了整个任务，那么每个人都会输，所以这有点像你必须在任务中艰难前行，尽可能多地在背后捅对方一刀，而不会做得太过火导致任务失败，所以它真的采用了整个《龙与地下城》的体验，并使它变得非常令人兴奋，我玩过一点《龙与地下城》，但我从来没能真正投入进去，但我绝对喜欢这个，而且它是真的很过时，特别是作为一本有点科幻主题的书，它确实显露了它的年龄，所以这个 Kickstarter 是重写它的一种方式，你知道，为了现代观众，我真的很期待它。我的书本来应该是金·斯坦利·罗宾逊的《红火星》，那是我上次通过说我不太感兴趣而极力铺垫的那一本，结果书读完了，
you fail the entire mission then everybody loses so it's sort of like you have to limp along through the mission uh just stabbing each other in the back as many times as possible without going overboard and losing the mission so it really takes the whole dnd experience and makes it like it makes it really exciting like i played a little bit of dnd and i could never really get into it but this i just absolutely loved um and um it's the thing is it's really dated especially being sort of a sci-fi theme book it's definitely showing its age so this kickstarter is is a way to rewrite it you know for a modern audience and i'm really looking forward to it my book was going to be red planet by kim stanley robinson that was the one i was terribly foreshadowing last time by saying i wasn't that into it turned out the book ended and
我还是不太感兴趣，所以我决定不把它作为推荐给你，如果你对火星地球化及其经济学的长篇枯燥讨论感兴趣，而且嘿，火星上有水，所以我们现在可以做到了，这是这本书谈论的内容，哦太棒了，埃隆·马斯克谈论核轰炸火星作为启动地球化的一种方式也是书中谈论的内容。好吧。所以这本书，我的意思是，在这方面是准确且有趣的。
i still wasn't that into it and so i've decided not to give you that as a recommendation if you're interested in a really long form dry discussion of terraforming on mars and economics of that and hey there's water there's water on mars so we could do that now which is something this book talks about oh great and elon musk talking about nuclear bombing mars as a way to to kickstart terraforming is also something kind of they talk about in the book. Okay. So the book is, I mean, it's accurate and interesting in that regard.
只是对于那个主题来说，这是一本相当长的书。明白了。所以相反，我还没读完这本书。我读了一半左右，但我目前真的很喜欢它。那就是约翰·斯卡尔齐相对较新的书《锁闭》，这本书讲述了一个不久的将来，人们感染了一种流感或类似流感的病毒，它改变了他们的大脑并使他们瘫痪，就像社会中有一大部分人变得“锁闭”了，他们无法移动，他们必须以虚拟方式或通过使用类似
It's just a pretty long book for that. Got it. So instead, I'm not finished with the book. I'm about halfway through it, but I'm really enjoying it thus far. And that's John Scalzi's relatively new book lock in and uh this book is about a near future where people get a flu or flu-like virus that alters their brain and makes them paralyzed and kind of like there's a whole portion of society that becomes locked in where they can't move and they have to do everything kind of virtually or like through the use of like
安卓机器人的方式来做所有事情，哦哇，所以那不是剧透，那简直就是书的前五页，不，是的，是的，所以这说得通，总之这真的很有趣，我实际上是在 Audible 上听这本书。如果你有兴趣尝试 Audible，很多人都在这样做，所以请把你们用 Audible 免费书听的内容发给我们。你可以去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，
android robots oh wow so that's not spoiling that's like literally like the first five pages of the book no yeah yeah so that makes sense that's anyways it's really interesting and i'm actually listening to this book on Audible. And if you're interested in trying Audible, which a lot of people have been doing, so send us in what you are listening to with your Audible free book. And you can go to audibletrial.com slash programmingthrowdown,
全部连在一起，小写，programmingthrowdown。所以是 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。你可以得到一本免费的书。我们也会得到一点点帮助来维持节目的运行，而你得到了一本免费的书，即使你取消订阅也可以保留。我每个月有一本书，我总是能找到很棒的东西来听，他们有成千上万本书，即使其中一些真的很烂，比如《红火星》，是的，我的意思是，如果你真的喜欢它，那没关系，但是的，它还可以，非常酷，这比我在开车上班时再次听音乐要好。是的，没错，只有
all one word, lowercase for programmingthrowdown. So that's audibletrial.com slash programmingthrowdown. You can get a free book. And we get a little bit of something to help us keep the show running and you get a book for free that you get to keep even if you cancel your subscription i have one book a month that i get uh and i always find something awesome to listen to they have tons and tons and tons of books even if some of them are real like losers like red planet red mars yeah i mean you don't have if you really like it it's just it but yeah it's okay very cool it was better than sitting listening to music again on my drive into work yeah right there's only told
Spotify 上只有那么多的芯片音乐，嘿，你也听那个频道吗？是的，我喜欢那个频道，我不会，我得到的新频道是什么？那是非常奇怪的东西。我得想想那是什么。哦，好吧。就像 Disco EDM 之类的。真的吗？好吧。是的，我当时想，哦，好吧。
only so many chiptunes on spotify hey you listen to that channel too yeah i love that channel i wouldn't what's the new one I got? It was something very strange. I'll have to think of what it was. Oh, okay. It's like Disco EDM or something. Really? Okay. Yeah, I was like, oh, okay.
是的，是的。好吧，本期工具时间。本期工具。所以我的本期工具，有一对工具。什么？那不公平。我知道，完全是在作弊。第一个是 ImageMagick，现在这是 ImageMagick，就像英国版本，所以是 m-a-g-i-c-k，ImageMagick，它是一个用于处理图像的库，它有十亿种不同的绑定，我还没查过，但我很确定有一个
Yeah, yeah. Okay, time for tool of the show. Tool of the show. So my tool of the show, there's a pair of tools. What? That's not fair. I know, totally cheating. the first is image magic now this is image magic like the british version so it's m-a-g-i-c-k uh image magic um and it is a library for working with images and uh it has a billion different bindings i haven't checked but I'm pretty sure there is a
Ruby 绑定，让我现在查一下，哦是的，有，有 RMagick，是的，所以实际上有两个，所以是的，ImageMagick 无处不在，每个人都在使用 ImageMagick，如果你在处理图像，它很棒，还有 FFmpeg
ruby binding let me check right now oh yes there is there is our magic yes so there's actually two so so yeah there's image magic is ubiquitous just everyone uses image magic if you're doing things with images it's great also FFmpeg
它和 ImageMagick 处理视频的思路是一样的，尽管名字叫 mpeg，但它做的远不止 mpeg，它处理 wmv，它处理 avi，它处理 mp4，我刚才说是 mpeg，但它处理所有东西
it's it's in the same vein as image magic for videos despite the name it does way more than mpeg it does wmv, it does avi it does mp4 which I said is mpeg but it does everything
而且它无处不在，它有每种语言的绑定，所以如果你需要处理图像或者你需要处理视频，你就会使用 ImageMagick 或 FFmpeg。它们自己编译起来非常困难。我记得有一次我花了一个月的时间才让 FFmpeg 在 Windows 上构建成功。希望现在很多情况已经好转了
and it's ubiquitous it's bindings for every language so if you need to work with images or you need to work with video or you need to work with video, you're going to be using ImageMagick or FFmpeg. They're just brutally difficult to compile yourself. I remember one time I spent almost a month getting FFmpeg to even build on Windows. Hopefully a lot of that is better now
我有使用 FFmpeg 的经验，有一个可执行文件的压缩包你可以下载，是的，没错，所以它们绝对是巨大的单体项目，如果不需要，不要尝试自己构建它。幸运的是，大多数人不需要
I have experience with FFmpeg there's like a zip of executables you can download yeah that's right so definitely they're huge monolithic projects don't try and build it yourself if you don't have to fortunately most people don't have to
因为几乎所有东西都有绑定。所以去看看它们。它们很棒。我已经在很多不同的项目中使用过它们。我们最近有一个项目，我们在视频上做一些机器学习，我们想在视频上放一些仪表，只是在视频上画一些仪表，比如注释视频，我们使用了 FFmpeg 来做这件事，
because there are just bindings for everything. So check them out. They're great. I've used them for so many different projects. We had a thing recently where we were doing some machine learning on videos, and we wanted to sort of put some instrumentation, just draw some instrumentation on the video, like annotate the video, and we used FFmpeg to do that,
效果非常好。我使用 FFmpeg 的另外两件事是将视频转换为静态图像，比如每一帧都变成它自己的文件，还有我拍的，这真的很奇怪和俗气，但不管怎样，我每年都会拍一个搭建圣诞树的延时摄影，我只是用我的单反相机拍，因为这是我现在习惯的方式，
and it came out really nicely. The other thing, two things I use FFmpeg for are taking a video and converting it to stills, so like every frame to its own file, and also I took, it's really weird and cheesy, but whatever, and converting it to stills, so like every frame to its own file. And also I took, it's really weird and cheesy, but whatever. I take a time lapse of putting up the Christmas tree each year, and I just take it with my SLR camera because this is what I'm used to now,
虽然现在我可能会用手机拍，因为我添加了这个功能。我通常把它拍成一大堆静态图像，然后我用 FFmpeg 把它们全部压成一个视频文件，是的，这说得通，而且非常简单直接，比尝试在视频编辑器之类的软件中打开一大堆高像素图像要容易得多，它们往往会变慢，是的，我的意思是，那样做会非常痛苦，因为这有点傻，因为 1080p 视频是，什么，每帧两百万像素或者其他什么，但像单反，是的，像 800 万或 1200 万像素的图像，所以是的，是的，如果你对具有高光学质量的东西进行下采样，你会得到更好的质量吗？所以我不知道，视频对我来说
although now I'll probably do it with my phone since I've added this feature. I typically take it as a whole bunch of still images, and then I use FFmpeg to smash them all into a video file yep that makes sense and it's just really super easy and straightforward much easier than like trying to open a whole bunch of high megapixel images in uh you know like a video editor or something they tend to bog down yeah i mean that would be just brutally painful to do that because it's kind of silly because a 1080p video is what it like a mega no two megapixels per frame or whatever but like an slr yeah like eight megapixel or 12 megapixel images so yeah yeah is it um is it is it you get better quality if you down sample a something with high optical quality does that does that so i don't know the videos for me turn
效果非常好，我想也许我应该试着弄清楚我的手机，我用相机拍的原因是我可以把它调成全手动模式，这意味着对焦保持不变，设置保持不变。是的，没错。这样你就不会得到奇怪的效果，比如某些帧对焦改变，或者当有人走近或走远时，他们可能会稍微失焦，但至少整个对焦不会前后移动，这会稍微扭曲视图。是的。
out really good and i which i i guess maybe i should try to figure out my phone the reason why i do it my camera is i can put it in fully manual mode, which means the focus stays constant and the settings stay constant. Yeah, right. And so then you don't get like weird effects like some frames being focus changing or when someone walks nearer or farther to the camera, they may go in or out of focus slightly, but at least the whole focus isn't shifting forward and back, which distorts the view slightly. Yeah.
我的意思是，我想，如果你有一台相机在拍摄一定的分辨率，这意味着光子撞击这些单元，而单元桶有一定的尺寸。所以如果你有更高的像素，假设光圈大小相同，那么你有更多更小的
I mean, I guess, so if you have a camera that's taking a certain resolution, what that means are like photons are hitting these cells and the cell buckets have a certain size. So if you have a higher megapixel, assuming like the aperture size is the same, then you have more smaller
桶，但当你下采样时，你只是在平均这些桶。我想我不知道，我只是对光学了解不够，不知道如果你用单反相机下采样，还是只用 iPhone 拍照，假设你的 iPhone 上有某种手动模式，我不知道哪个更好。另一件事是，你知道，我通常在很长一段时间或两个很长的时间段内拍摄，我发现手机非常适合你想拍短视频的时候，但像延时摄影之类的，你想拍很长的时间，或者两个很长的时间段，我发现手机非常适合你想拍短视频的时候，但像延时摄影之类的，你想拍一个很长的，我想
buckets, but then you're just averaging those buckets when you downsample. I guess i don't know i just don't know enough about optics to know like if you take your slr and down sample it versus just taking pictures with your iphone assuming there was some manual mode on your iphone i don't know which one's better the other thing is like the you know i typically take it over the course of like a long period of time or two long periods of time and i find phones work great for when you just want to like take a short video but like time lapses and stuff you want to take a long period of time or two long periods of time and i find phones work great for when you just want to like take a short video but like time lapses and stuff you want to take a long one i want
调整速度，我可能想加快某些部分，放慢其他部分，我从来没有掌握在手机上做到这一点的诀窍。是的，是的，我同意。酷，好的，非常酷。我的本期工具是 Personal Capital，我不知道你是否在谈论，不，你在另一个节目上谈论了别的东西，我以为我谈论了 Wealthfront，但我不认为我谈论过这个，所以 Personal Capital 是 Wealthfront 和 Mint 的结合体，啊，所以，我不使用，他们运行两者，他们称之为机器人顾问，这是一种让你投资资金并以低费率推荐 ETF 的方式，或者其他什么。
to adjust the speed i may want to speed up some parts and slow down others and i've just never gotten in the knack of being able to do that on my phone yeah yeah i agree cool all right very cool my tool of the show is personal capital i don't know if you were you were talking about no you talked about something else on another show i was thinking i talked about wealth front but i don't think i've ever talked about this so personal capital is a combination of wealth front and mint ah so um i don't use they so they run both a robo advisor is what they call it which is like a way for you to invest money with them and recommended ETFs at low rates or whatever.
好的，但我对他们所做的那部分不感兴趣。但他们也运行一项类似于 Mint 的服务，建立在 Yodlee 之上，是吗，这是连接到金融服务的 API 后端，这不是 Mint 使用的。Mint 使用他们自己的，所以连接性实际上在 Personal Capital 中比 Mint 更好，而且 Mint 在日常消费方面真的很好，但在我看来，在投资方面不太好，所以如果你
Okay, but I'm not interested in that part of what they do. But they run also a service that's similar to Mint on top of Yodlee, is it, which is the API backend for connecting to financial services, which is not what Mint uses. Mint rolls their own so the connectivity is actually a little better in personal capital than mint and mint is really good for like day-to-day spending and kind of not so good in my opinion for like investment so if
有任何股票或 401k 之类的钱，Personal Capital 在跟踪方面做得好得多。它还会告诉你，比如你目前投资了太多的债券或太多的现金或太多的其他东西，对吧？根据你这个年龄应该达到的水平，基于一些建议，你可能同意也可能不同意。但它做的分析我觉得很有趣，也很有帮助。所以我本周推荐它。这家公司怎么生存？他们从哪里赚钱？因为他们可以向你推荐服务，对吧，就像 Mint 一样，他们在某种程度上进行销售，是的，你可能觉得舒服也可能不舒服，但对他们来说，有一件事是他们试图让你，我没有
you have any sort of like money in stocks or a you know 401k or whatever personal capital does a much better job of like explain like tracking that And it'll also give you like you are currently invested in too many bonds or too much cash or too much whatever, right? According to like, you know, where you should be at your age based on some recommendation, which you may or may not agree with. But it does analysis that I find interesting to see and helpful. And so I recommend that this week. How does this company stay alive? like where do they make their money because they can recommend you services right like same thing as mint they're selling at some level which yes you may or may not be comfortable with um but for them one thing is that they try to get you to which i've i didn't
觉得这种推动力非常大，或者至少我没有遇到过，但对于使用他们的咨询基金，他们会获得一小部分百分比，一旦你使用了一定数量的钱，就像 Wealthfront 一样，对吧，比如几千美元之后，他们获得一个百分比，是的，没错，不是整个百分比，而是百分比的一小部分，对吧，对吧，但看起来这些人不像 Mint 那样做，从某种意义上说，他们是否真的连接到你的银行之类的，是的，哦，他们那样做，好的，是的，还有你的信用卡，因为他们连接到你的信用卡，好的，因为从首页看，听起来它完全是关于你的投资，而不是你的日常，不，它两者都做，但
feel like the push is very hard or at least i haven't had it but for using their you know advisory fund thing in which they get some small percentage once you use a certain amount of money same thing as wealth front right like after so many thousand dollars they get a percent yeah right right not a whole percent but some fraction of a percent right right but the it doesn't look like these guys do the mint thing in a sense like they don't do they actually connect to your bank and stuff like that yeah oh they do that okay yeah and your credit card like they connect to your credit card okay because it's from the front page it sounds like it's all about just your investments not really your day-to-day no it does both but
酷的地方在于，日常部分没那么好，对吧，在我看来 Mint 在那方面更好，对吧，对吧，但这在投资方面更好，所以值得使用，而且日常部分你无论如何都得自己看，对吧，就像 Mint 可以告诉你一些事情，但实际上你应该只看你的支出，然后说，好的，那是一个错误，或者你需要削减，好吧，我真的很喜欢用 Mint，因为我有几张信用卡，或者其他什么，用于不同的目的，它会把它们全部加在一起，等等，等一下，你为什么有几张信用卡？所以我有一张高奖励的，这太个人了，不管怎样，我从 16 岁起就只有一张信用卡，一直都是同一张，如果你能控制它，有几个很好的理由，而且这是，这太偏离播客的主题了，好的，是的，但总之，基本上就像一张奖励卡，但它是美国运通卡，不是到处都接受，所以你需要，哦，明白了，但总的来说，确保你有一张借记卡和一张信用卡也很好，但你应该至少有两张，以防万一其中一张有问题，或者在别处被使用，他们不得不暂时锁定你的账户，那是真的，有几次，嗯，我的信用卡出了问题，我没有备份，所以这是一个很好的观点，是的，所以它确实很好，总之，抱歉
the cool thing like the day-to-day isn't as good right like mint is better for that in my opinion right right um but this is better for the investments so it's worth using and the day-to-day you kind of have to the day-to-day you have to look at yourself anyways right like mint could tell you some things but really you should just look at your your expenses and just say okay that that's a mistake or you need to cut down well i'm really like using mint for having i have you know several credit cards or whatever for different purposes and like it will accumulate them all together for me wait hold on a second why do you have several credit cards so i have a high rewards this is so personal whatever i have a high like a reward because i've only ever had one credit card ever since i was
我不认为 Personal Capital 对我们所有不在美国的听众有效，所有那些可能想说“我想要一份工作，而你现在在谈论如何投资”的人，但是的，总有一天我们都可以渴望我们有足够的钱来投资和担心，所以我的意思是，每个人都能同意的一点是，他们希望他们做得更好，就像他们在开始时就知道更多关于这一点，因为那是它最重要的时候，也是你知道得最少的时候，绝对是这样，这就是我觉得我所处的位置，这就是为什么我想我试着，你看到那些图表，比如你在 30 岁之前投资的每一美元，当你 50 岁时价值数百美元，对吧，对吧，我实际上没有，我
like 16 years old it's been the same there's a couple good reasons if you're if you can control it and are this is not this is so off topic for the podcast okay yeah but anyways basically like a rewards card but it's an american express which isn't accepted everywhere so then you need to oh got it but in general it's also good to make sure you could have a debit card in a credit card but you should have at least two some things in case you know one of them has a problem or you know gets used somewhere else and they have to lock your account you know temporarily that's true there have been a handful of times where um my there's been an issue with my credit card and i yeah i had no backup so that's a good point yes so it is good anyways and sorry for that
没有，前两三年我没有存满，对吧，对吧，我实际上没有，前两三年我没有存满我的 401k，只是因为我不真正理解它意味着什么，或者其他什么，所以是的，孩子们，不要那样做，如果你能存满你的 401k，是的，总之，让我们谈谈 Ruby，你现在听起来像个非常老的人，就像，是的，年轻的小伙子们，是的，那没过多久，伙计们，我没那么老，但，但，但，是的，我工作了几年，如果你收听这个，这是一个编程播客，我们保证，我在行业里工作了 11 年，前两三年我没有存满我的 401k，所以不要那样做，你在行业里工作多久了，然后我们谈谈 Ruby，我
i don't think personal capital works for all of our listeners who aren't in the u.s and all those people who may be like what i would like a job and now you're talking about how to invest money but yeah one day we can all aspire that we have enough money to invest and worry about so i mean one thing everyone can agree on is that uh they wish they had done better like they'd known more about this when they started because that's when it matters the most and that's when you know the least absolutely and that's where i feel like i'm at and that's why i guess i try to be you see those graphs of like every dollar you invest when you're under 30 is worth you know hundreds of dollars you invest when you're 50 right right i actually didn't i
只是好奇，我想我工作了八年，好的，也许我没有 11 年，也许我 10 年，我不知道，总之，我在本科毕业后就开始工作了，因为我在工作时读了硕士学位，好的，明白了，明白了，是的，总之，再次偏离主题，所以 Ruby。所以我有一个引言。我想读这个引言。好的，继续吧。这与 Ruby 的背景有关。这是由 Ruby 的发明者、设计师、创造者、负责人松本说的。
didn't the first two or three years i didn't max right right i actually didn't i didn't the first two or three years i didn't max out my 401k just because i didn't really understand what it meant or anything um so yeah don't do that kids if you if you can max out your 401k yeah anyway so let's talk about ruby you sound like a really old guy now like yeah young whippersnappers yeah it wasn't that long ago guys i'm not that old but but uh uh but yeah there was a couple of years i've been working if you tuned in this is a programming podcast we promise i've been in industry what 11 years and and the first two or three years i didn't max my 401k so don't do that um how long have you been in industry and then we'll talk about ruby i'm
可能说错了。他是日本人。这就是 Ruby 的来源。这是这个引言。我真的很喜欢这个。我希望看到 Ruby 帮助世界上每一位程序员提高生产力，享受编程，并感到快乐，这就是 Ruby 语言的主要目的，这太棒了，他希望我们快乐，是的，我的意思是，这比 Fortran 好多了，Fortran 希望导弹模拟更准确，Ruby，他们希望你更准确。Ruby，他们希望你快乐。
just curious i think i'm at eight years okay maybe i'm not at 11 then maybe i'm at 10 i don't know anyway i did it right after undergrad i started working because i did my master's degree while i was working okay got it got it yep anyways again so off topic so rub Ruby. So I have a quote. I want to read this quote. Okay, go for it. This is related to sort of like background for Ruby. And this is by the inventor, designer, creator, the head honcho guy for Ruby, Matsumoto.
我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。我觉得这很好。这非常有预见性。等等，我不知道它。但总之，是的。所以总之，这是一些背景。所以为了给你 Ruby 来源的方向，
Probably saying it wrong. He's Japanese. That's where Ruby comes from. And here's this quote. I really like this. I hope to see Ruby help every programmer in the world to be productive and to enjoy programming and to be happy that is the primary purpose of the ruby language that's awesome he wants us to be happy yeah i mean it's way better than fortran which wanted missile simulation to be more accurate ruby they want you to be more accurate. Ruby, they want you to be happy.
它应该是一个快乐和高效的环境。是的，这说得通。我确实认为有很多，而且我保证，这是最后一次咆哮，但快乐和高效之间有很多联系，就像很多人说，哦，我真的希望我的孩子们快乐，或者我的配偶快乐，但实际上让某人快乐有点难，但你绝对可以让某人高效，或者至少不是让，但你绝对可以，给人们提供建议和方向让他们更高效要容易得多，如果这导致了快乐
I like that. I like that. I thought that was nice. It's very prophetic. Wait, I don't know about it. But anyway, yeah. So anyways, that's some background. So to give you the direction Ruby is coming from,
那么这比试图直接让他们快乐要容易得多，总之，好的，所以，是的，所以 Ruby 是，人们不知道，那些从未见过 Ruby 或对 Ruby 一无所知的人，它类似于 Python。你知道，它们都是解释型的。你会说这是它最接近的竞争对手吗？我会说 Python 绝对是最接近的竞争对手。你说的另一个是什么？不，我要说，我只是在换个说法，比如，最接近的竞争对手。我认为 Python 可能比 Ruby 更受欢迎，所以。
it's supposed to be a happy and productive environment. Yeah, that makes sense. I do think there's a lot of, and this, I promise, is the last rant rant but there's a lot of connection between being happy and being productive and like a lot of people say oh i really want my kids to be happy or my spouse to be happy and it's actually kind of hard to make somebody happy but you can definitely make someone productive or at least not make but you could definitely it's much easier to give people like advice and direction that makes them more productive and if that leads to happiness
是的，我认为它们很受欢迎且不同。比如，Ruby 可能比 Ruby 更受欢迎，所以是的，我认为它们很受欢迎且不同，比如 Ruby 在 Web 上更受欢迎，比如 Python 有 Django，这类似于 Ruby on Rails，但你知道，远没有那么受欢迎，当涉及到科学方面的东西时，Python 只是更受欢迎，所以它们都有各自的利基，但它们都是解释型的。Ruby 实际上在 RedMonk 编程语言排名中排名第五，这很酷，这些人他们获取 Stack Overflow 上的评论数量和 GitHub 项目的数量，并以某种方式把它们全部扔进
then there's a much easier way to make people happy than to try to make them happy directly anyway uh okay so uh yeah so ruby is uh people don't know, who've never seen Ruby or know anything about Ruby, it's similar to Python. You know, they're both interpreted. Would you say that's its closest competitor? I would say Python is definitely the closest competitor. What was the other one you said? No, I was going to say, I was just rephrasing, like, closest competitor. I think Python is probably more popular than Ruby, so.
算法中，然后吐出前 21 种语言。Python 是第四名，而 Ruby 实际上与 C++ 和 C# 并列第五。我真的不知道当他们考虑这么多事情时，你怎么能并列。但是的，Ruby 绝对名列前茅。所以它是一种流行的语言。这是一个值得了解的好语言。但编程语言第八名是 CSS。
Yeah, I think they're popular and different. Like, Ruby probably more popular than ruby so yeah i think they're they're popular and different like ruby's more popular for web um like python has the django which is you know similar to ruby on rails but you know not anywhere near as popular um and when it comes like scientific stuff python is just way way more popular so um they both have their sort of niches but they're both interpreted Ruby was actually number 5 in the RedMonk programming language rankings which is pretty cool these guys they take the number of comments on Stack Overflow and the number of GitHub projects and kind of throw it all together in some
我不知道。什么？那有什么问题？外面有很多 CSS。不，我……是的。是的。不，我要……
algorithm and then spit out the top 21 languages. And Python was number four, and Ruby was actually tied for number five with C++ and C Sharp. I don't really know how you can be tied when they take in so many things. But yeah, Ruby is definitely up there. So it's a popular language. It's a good one to know about. But programming language number eight is CSS.
算了。让我们继续吧。好的，我的意思是，是的。所以……外面有很多 CSS。那不是我要去的地方，算了。让我们继续吧。好的，我的意思是，是的。外面有很多 CSS。那不是我要去的地方。你认为 CSS 更像是内容而不是语言？我知道如果我查一下，CSS 是否是图灵完备的，答案是肯定的。
I don't know. What? What's wrong with that? There's a lot of CSS out there. No, I... Yeah. Yeah. No, I'm going to...
当然，当然。但我认为你的观点是，有很多 CSS 只是在描述事物。那真的不是源代码。它真的是输出，对吧？我的意思是，事实上，它字面上可以是输出，因为有 LESS 和 SASS 以及其他编译成 CSS 的编程语言。事实上，没有那么多专业开发人员再编写 CSS，比如原始 CSS 了。这有点像说，哦，最流行的编程语言是机器语言。但总之，所以让 Ruby 如此流行的原因之一是 Ruby on Rails，它是
Never mind. Let's just move on. Okay. I mean, yeah. So... There is a lot of CSS out there. That was not where I'm going to, never mind. Let's just move on. Okay. I mean, yeah. There is a lot of CSS out there. That was not where I was going to go. You're thinking CSS is more like content than a language? I know if I look up, is CSS Turing complete, the answer is going to be yes.
一种用 Ruby 编写的模型-视图-控制器 Web 框架。所以我将简要谈谈那个。所以 MVC 框架，模型-视图-控制器框架，有三种组件。有模型。模型通常从自动生成开始。这被称为对象关系模型，或 ORM。你实际上可以在 Ruby on Rails 中做一些事情，叫做脚手架
Of course, of course. But I think to your point, there's a lot of CSS that is just describing things. That's really not source code. It's really output, right? I mean, in fact, it literally can be output because there's LESS and SAS and other programming languages that compile to CSS. And in fact, not that many professional developers write CSS, like raw CSS anymore. It's sort of like saying, oh, the most popular programming language is machine language. But anyway, so one of the things that made Ruby so popular is Ruby on Rails, which is
并说你正在编写一些非常小的元数据文件，它只是说一些简单的事情，比如，我有一个人，一个人有一个年龄，一个人有一个电话号码列表。你用这种非常紧凑的 DSL 编写，然后从那里它变成了一个完整的数据库，以及一堆代码来对该数据库做原始的事情，比如如果我想获取一个人或写一个人，诸如此类，所以模型很多是自动生成的，你可能想做，你知道，更具体的事情
a sort of model view controller web framework written in Ruby. And so I'll kind of talk about that briefly. So MVC framework, model view controller framework, has sort of three components. There's the model. The model usually starts out auto-generated. This is called a object relational Model, or ORM. You can actually do something in Ruby on Rails called scaffolding
在其中，你可能想说获取所有在过去一天更新了个人资料的人，所以那不会为你自动生成，你必须编写它，那将是模型的一部分。视图全部只是 HTML 和模板。所以想法是视图可能类似于打开标签，标题，关闭标签，你好，然后在括号中，人名，关闭括号。然后是控制器，它是第三部分，它负责填充所有那些括号。它负责知道人名意味着什么。它使用你在模型中编写的函数去获取人，然后告诉视图这是你需要的信息。
and say you're writing some very small metadata file which just says things as simple as, like, I have a person, and a person has an age, and a person has a list of phone numbers. You write in this very compact dsl and then from that it turns into an entire database and also a bunch of code to do primitive things with that database like if i want to fetch a person or write a person things like that so the model is a lot of it is auto-generated you may want to do you know more specific things
所以我不知道 Ruby on Rails 是否是第一个 MVC 框架，但它绝对是目前为止最受欢迎的。有大量的教程和其他参考资料，我们将在最后谈论。而且它也很酷。通过脚手架，它实际上支持不同的数据库，这非常棒。你实际上可以使用 SQLite 原型化你的网站。你只是在你的机器上运行，没有任何数据库服务
in that you may want to say get all the people that have updated their profile in the past day so that's not going to be auto-generated for you you'll have to write that that would be part of the model the view is all just HTML and templates. So the idea is view might be something like open tag, header, close tag, hello, and then in brackets, person name, close brackets. And then the controller, which is the third piece, it's responsible for filling in all those brackets. It's responsible for knowing what person name means. It uses the functions you wrote in the model to go and fetch people and then tell the view this is the information you need.
然后将你的 Ruby on Rails 项目复制到你的服务器上，该服务器正在运行 MySQL，并在该服务器上运行完全相同的代码，它就神奇地工作了，这非常酷，神奇地
So I don't know if Ruby on Rails was the first MVC framework, but it's definitely the most popular by far. There's a ton of tutorials and other references, which we'll talk about at the end. And it also, it's pretty cool. With the scaffolding, it actually supports different databases, which is pretty awesome. You can actually prototype your website using SQLite. You're just running on your machine without any database service
这是脚手架的魔力，所以 Ruby on Rails 完全棒极了，它现在可能有点过时了，我不知道它维护得如何，我肯定不像以前那样经常听到它，但它是我用过几次的项目，它非常出色，我想它也被提升到……Ruby on Rails 真的被……推了很多，哦，为什么名字刚才从我脑海中溜走了？哦，不。
and then copy your Ruby on Rails project over to your server which is running MySQL and run the exact same code on that server and it just magically works, it's pretty cool magically
大脑崩溃。哦，好吧。Ruby 受欢迎的原因之一，我认为也是因为它支持很多不同的编程方式。所以 Python 也有这个优势。比如你可以在 Python 中做脚本，或者你可以在 Python 中编写面向对象的东西。是的。Ruby 也有类似的东西，它确实支持很多不同的方式。
it's the magic of scaffolding so uh ruby on rails totally awesome uh it might be a bit dated now i don't know how well it's maintained i haven't i definitely don't hear about it as much as i used to um but uh it's i've used it for a few projects it's phenomenal um i think also it got promoted to... Ruby on Rails was really pushed a lot by the... Oh, why did the name just escape me? Oh, no.
它只是试图避开你的路，允许你以非常灵活的方式做很多事情，这样你就可以用 Ruby 为不同的问题编写不同的编码风格。是的，这是 Ruby 比 Python 做得更好的一个地方。在 Python 中，类以一种非常愚蠢的方式处理。基本上，类只是一组函数。我不会把它弄对，因为它非常微妙，但在 Python 的底层，类就像是一种事后想法
Brain meltdown. Oh, well. One of the things that Ruby, I think, is popular because of is also it supports a lot of different ways of programming. So Python also has this as an advantage. Like you can do scripting in Python or you can write object-oriented stuff in Python. Yep. And Ruby has a similar thing where it really does support lots of different ways.
而且它有点被黑客攻击在那里，但在 Ruby 中，类完全是它们自己的实体，它们以一种更优雅的方式处理。Ruby 的另一件事是你可以做非常优雅的元编程，换句话说，如果你有一个，如果你有一个类，而类是一组方法，并且你想得到，你知道，方法
It just tries to get out of your way and allow you to do lots of stuff in a very flexible manner so that you can write in Ruby different coding styles for different problems. Yeah, and this is one place where Ruby does better than Python. In Python, a class is handled in a really goofy way. Basically, a class is just a collection of functions. I'm not going to get this right because it's very nuanced but under the hood in Python a class is just like kind of an afterthought
类的名称，实际的函数名称，你知道，你可以很容易地做到这一点，比如你枚举所有的方法，实际的函数名称，你知道，你可以很容易地做到这一点。比如，你可以枚举给定对象的所有方法，诸如此类。你知道，你可以在 Python 中做到这一点。任何对象都有一个点下划线下划线 dict 下划线下划线
and it's kind of hacked on there but in Ruby classes are totally kind of their own entity and they're handled in a much more elegant way. Another thing with Ruby is you could do really elegant meta programming so in other words if you have if you have a if you have a class and the class is a list of methods and you want to get you know the method
对象或属性。使用该属性，你可以获取，你知道，你可以在 Python 中做元编程，但它绝对，正如我之前所说，它绝对是一种事后想法或某种黑客行为，你知道，最初可能并不打算成为 Python 的重要组成部分。但在 Ruby 中，这就像是一等公民，从某种意义上说，他们从一开始就考虑到了这一点。这就是为什么 Ruby 非常适合领域特定语言的原因之一，我们确实有请求谈论它，我们将来会谈论它，是的，绝对，但简而言之，它就像你定义的一种新语言，但你并没有试图做所有事情，比如你并没有真正编写一种完整的语言，好吧，你是，但你并没有编写一种
names of the class of actual function names you know you can do that pretty easily like you enumerate all of the methods for the actual function names, you know, you can do that pretty easily. Like, you can enumerate all of the methods for a given object and things like that. You know, you could do this in Python. Any object has a dot underscore underscore dict underscore underscore
实际函数名称类的名称，你知道你可以很容易地做到这一点，比如你可以枚举实际函数名称的所有方法，你知道，你可以很容易地做到这一点。就像你可以枚举给定对象的所有方法等等。你知道，你可以在 Python 中这样做。任何对象都有一个点下划线下划线 dict 下划线下划线
object or property. And using that property, you can fetch, you know, you can do metaprogramming in Python, but it's definitely, as I said before, it's definitely kind of an afterthought or some hacky thing that, you know, probably wasn't intended in the beginning to be a big part of Python. But in Ruby, that's kind of like a first class citizen in the sense like they kind of thought about that from the beginning. And that's one of the reasons why Ruby is so good for domain specific languages um which we did have a request to talk about and we will in the future yep yeah definitely but briefly it's like a new language you define but you're not trying to do everything like you're not really writing a whole language well you are but you're not writing a
对象或属性。利用该属性，你可以获取，你知道，你可以在 Python 中进行元编程，但正如我之前所说，这绝对是一种事后补救或某种黑客手段，你知道，最初可能并不打算将其作为 Python 的重要组成部分。但在 Ruby 中，这就像是一等公民，因为他们从一开始就考虑到了这一点。这也是 Ruby 非常适合领域特定语言的原因之一，嗯，我们确实收到了关于讨论这个话题的请求，我们将来会讨论的，是的，绝对会，但简而言之，它就像是你定义的一种新语言，但你并不是试图做所有事情，比如你并不是真的在编写一种完整的语言，好吧，你是在编写，但你并不是在编写一个
language to do everything not a general purpose language a very domain specific something for a specific niche a specific application um so like scripting an ai in a video game right like you may want to have a configuration language for doing that that actually gets executed but it doesn't need to necessarily be turing complete or does it need to be a from it may look a lot like ruby um and ruby supports that really well it has a lot of them because of this really good meta programming reflection introspection yep i mean you might want a dsl that's very specific so that you can make a lot of assumptions about the DSL. For example, in Ruby on Rails, there's a DSL for defining your model. They make a lot of assumptions, and based on those assumptions, they can turn your model into SQL commands. They can't just turn generic Ruby code into SQL commands.
语言可以做任何事情，而不是一种通用语言，而是一种非常特定于领域的语言，用于特定的利基市场或特定的应用程序。比如在视频游戏中编写人工智能脚本，你可能想要一种配置语言来完成这项工作，它实际上会被执行，但它不一定需要是图灵完备的，或者它可能看起来很像 Ruby，而 Ruby 对此支持得非常好。因为它有非常好的元编程、反射和内省能力，所以它有很多这样的 DSL。我的意思是，你可能想要一个非常具体的 DSL，这样你就可以对 DSL 做出很多假设。例如，在 Ruby on Rails 中，有一个用于定义模型的 DSL。他们做出了很多假设，并基于这些假设，他们可以将你的模型转换为 SQL 命令。他们不能仅仅将通用的 Ruby 代码转换为 SQL 命令。
That would be too hard so the DSL tightens the assumptions on the language and because of that lets you do really cool things one of the cons about Ruby it's again it's a double edged sword here so take con with a grain of salt but it's
那太难了，所以 DSL 收紧了对语言的假设，正因为如此，它让你能够做一些非常酷的事情。Ruby 的缺点之一，这又是一把双刃剑，所以对缺点要持保留态度，但它是
dynamically typed and it's interpreted and so what that means is if you spell something wrong, you know, variable name wrong, if you change a function to, you know, accept a string instead of a number and you didn't change all the places that use that function, you're not going to find out about that until you run the code. So if, you know, if you're talking about, say, Homebrew, which is the Mac package manager that's written in Ruby, where you just hit some command and then after a minute it's done, that doesn't really matter. It's like now you found out about the bug after 50 seconds instead of two seconds or something.
动态类型的，而且是解释型的。这意味着如果你拼写错误，比如变量名写错了，或者如果你修改了一个函数，让它接受字符串而不是数字，而你没有修改所有使用该函数的地方，那么直到你运行代码时你才会发现。所以，如果你谈论的是 Homebrew，也就是用 Ruby 编写的 Mac 包管理器，你只需输入某个命令，一分钟后它就完成了，这其实没关系。就像你是在 50 秒后而不是 2 秒后发现错误一样。
So it's not that big a deal. But if you're building a website, there might be bugs that you don't find out about for a month and then they just start crashing. You don't know why. There's a really interesting Stack Overflow question about why Twitter switched from Ruby to Scala.
所以这没什么大不了的。但如果你正在构建一个网站，可能会有一些错误你一个月都发现不了，然后它们就开始崩溃了。你不知道为什么。关于 Twitter 为什么从 Ruby 转向 Scala，有一个非常有趣的 Stack Overflow 问题。
And the short answer is just that. They ran into too many problems where everything looks good and then at two in the morning, some code path gets executed that hadn't been before and things just start crashing. And so with Scala, if someone fat fingers a variable and spells it wrong, or if they change a function without letting everybody know uh you know scala just tells you right away before you deploy that code so are they still using scala i don't actually know i know they were yeah i know they were using for trying to use it for a fair amount of stuff before but are they using it for everything are they still um good question so
简短的回答就是这样。他们遇到了太多的问题，一切看起来都很好，然后在凌晨两点，一些以前从未执行过的代码路径被执行了，事情就开始崩溃了。所以对于 Scala，如果有人手误打错了一个变量名，或者如果他们在不通知大家的情况下修改了一个函数，Scala 会在部署代码之前立即告诉你。他们还在使用 Scala 吗？我其实不知道，我知道他们以前在很多事情上尝试使用它，但他们现在还在用它做所有事情吗？好问题，所以
i used to talk to a lot of people at Twitter. A lot of those people now aren't at Twitter anymore. So it's hard for me to really know. You know, definitely as of a year ago, or as of two years ago, they were definitely using Scala for almost everything. I heard actually, so I did hear sort of friend of a friend kind of thing.
我过去常和 Twitter 的很多人交谈。现在这些人中有很多已经不在 Twitter 了。所以我很难真正知道。你知道，肯定在一年或两年前，他们几乎在所有事情上都使用 Scala。我其实听说过，我是从朋友的朋友那里听说的。
So take this with a grain of salt. But I did hear that they were moving away from Scala I don't know why but maybe there's performance issues or something I don't know I do know Scala takes a very long time to compile so I don't know if that was why but yeah
所以对此要持保留态度。但我确实听说他们正在放弃 Scala，我不知道为什么，也许是因为性能问题或其他什么，我不知道。我确实知道 Scala 编译需要很长时间，所以我不知道是不是因为这个，但确实是这样。
I'm sure there's still a ton of code there written in Scala also Ruby just really never got adoption in scientific uses which is something Python got like huge adoption for use so there's a lot of really good examples and libraries for doing scientific computation, high precision math that kind of stuff in Python I'm sure there's no reason
我相信那里仍然有大量的代码是用 Scala 编写的。此外，Ruby 在科学用途上从未真正得到采用，而 Python 在这方面获得了巨大的采用。因此，在 Python 中有很多非常好的例子和库用于科学计算、高精度数学等。我相信没有理由
you couldn't do it in Ruby, but you're just not going to be going down the path of least resistance as far as having other people who have already done it. Yep. If you're going to do something scientific, just write up Python web service and
你不能在 Ruby 中做到这一点，但你只是不会走阻力最小的道路，因为没有其他人已经做过这些了。是的。如果你要做科学方面的事情，就写一个 Python Web 服务，然后
have Ruby call it. Don't try and do scientific stuff in Ruby. It's just going to be painful. Just for people who don't know, a lot of these scientific matrix operations and things like that, they really have to be done in C
让 Ruby 调用它。不要尝试在 Ruby 中做科学计算。那只会很痛苦。对于那些不知道的人来说，很多科学矩阵运算之类的事情，它们真的必须用 C 语言完成
or even Fortran. And so Python just has a bunch of bindings to those languages. And really the cool part about NumPy, SciPy, these libraries, are all of the C code that you don't have to write. So you can't just take the scientific libraries in Python and import them to Ruby. It won't be that easy.
甚至是 Fortran。所以 Python 只是拥有这些语言的一堆绑定。NumPy、SciPy 这些库真正酷的地方在于你不需要编写所有的 C 代码。所以你不能直接把 Python 中的科学库导入到 Ruby 中。没那么容易。
So yeah, that's definitely one area that wouldn't be fun to do in Ruby. It won't be that easy. That's definitely one area that wouldn't be fun to do in Ruby. You don't have to. You could definitely use both of these languages together. A great learning resource, which I think both Jason and I did, I never finished it, but I did do a fair
所以是的，这绝对是一个在 Ruby 中做起来不会很有趣的领域。没那么容易。这绝对是一个在 Ruby 中做起来不会很有趣的领域。你不必这样做。你绝对可以同时使用这两种语言。一个很好的学习资源，我想 Jason 和我都做过，我从来没有完成它，但我确实做了相当
amount of it, was the Rails for Zombies. We're terrible people. All these MOOCs, which I guess isn't exactly a MOOC, but sort of similar. amount of it was the rails for zombies but i did about terrible people all these moops which i guess isn't exactly a mook but sort of similar rails for zombies.org um and this is an interactive online uh tutorial which i was one of the very first ones i saw done like this now i see them all the time but very first ones i remember distinctly saying was this one and it takes you through all of the kind of steps of bringing up a ruby on rails website and it has a kind of funny theme with zombies and it's just it was a fun time and it's also educational for what would a ruby on
多的部分，就是 Rails for Zombies。我们是糟糕的人。所有这些 MOOC，我想这不完全是 MOOC，但有点类似。Rails for Zombies.org，这是一个交互式的在线教程，这是我见过的最早的此类教程之一，现在我经常看到它们，但我清楚地记得我看到的第一个就是这个。它带你完成了构建 Ruby on Rails 网站的所有步骤，它有一个关于僵尸的有趣主题，那是一段有趣的时光，对于了解 Ruby on Rails 开发是什么样子也很有教育意义。
what is developing a ruby on rails app look like yeah i also did about half of it I thought it was great definitely check why did you finish I'm just teasing I'm just he's no I mean I'm thinking about it I don't really know I'm calling the kettle black actually okay I know I didn't finish I remember it's because I got halfway through and I learned as much as I needed to know to build the site. And then I just started doing real work. That's what happened. So it's actually, I would say it was a win for them. Like they got me to the point where I was productive.
开发 Ruby on Rails 应用程序是什么样子？是的，我也做了大约一半，我觉得它很棒，一定要去看看。你为什么没完成？我只是在开玩笑。不，我是说我在考虑它，我真的不知道。我这是五十步笑百步。好吧，我知道我没完成，我记得是因为我做了一半，学到了构建网站所需的知识。然后我就开始做真正的工作了。这就是发生的事情。所以实际上，我会说这对他们来说是一个胜利。他们让我达到了可以提高生产力的程度。
Nice. Yeah, so definitely check it out. If you want to be productive in Rails, you have two people people here who who who took this class and then and then and then did some cool rail stuff so uh yeah check it out well thanks for listening yeah um just a couple of meta things oh first let's let's recap for people who skip to the end uh book of the show probably a good idea there was a lot of ranting this episode yeah book of the show is paranoia rpg uh and patrick's is lock-in uh tool this show i did image magic ffm peg and patrick did personal capital um so yeah so one thing uh we've had uh we're still like kind of dealing with some hosting provider issues and things like that
不错。是的，所以一定要去看看。如果你想在 Rails 中提高生产力，这里有两个人参加了这个课程，然后做了一些很酷的 Rails 项目，所以去看看吧。谢谢收听。是的，还有几件关于节目的事。哦，首先让我们为那些跳到最后的人回顾一下。本期节目的书，这可能是一个好主意，这一集有很多抱怨。是的，本期节目的书是《Paranoia RPG》，Patrick 的是《Lock-in》。本期节目的工具，我的是 ImageMagick 和 FFmpeg，Patrick 的是 Personal Capital。所以，有一件事，我们仍然在处理一些托管服务提供商的问题之类的事情。
we changed hosting providers and some people in Russia I got an email from someone in Russia who can't access it because the hosting provider is banned in Russia I have no idea why I'm pretty sure it has nothing to do with us
我们更换了托管服务提供商，俄罗斯的一些人，我收到了一封来自俄罗斯人的电子邮件，他们无法访问它，因为该托管服务提供商在俄罗斯被封禁了。我不知道为什么，我很确定这与我们无关。
because all those nasty things we said about the Russian government no we did nasty things we said about the Russian government. No, we did not say anything bad about the Russian government. Yeah, all those Vladimir Putin jokes we've been making. Stop. I don't know. So I'm sure it has something to do more with the domain, the top-level domain, and nothing to do with programming throwdown.
因为我们说的所有关于俄罗斯政府的那些刻薄的话。不，我们没有说任何关于俄罗斯政府的坏话。是的，我们一直在开的所有关于弗拉基米尔·普京的玩笑。停下。我不知道。所以我肯定这更多地与域名、顶级域名有关，而与 Programming Throwdown 无关。
But nonetheless, we're banned in Russia, which is kind of cool. Yeah, go us. I am going to host the podcast like an alternate place on S3. I did a lot of research into RSS. There's actually no way in the RSS feed for me to specify two sites.
但尽管如此，我们在俄罗斯被封禁了，这其实挺酷的。是的，为我们喝彩。我打算把播客托管在 S3 上的另一个地方。我做了很多关于 RSS 的研究。实际上，在 RSS 订阅源中，我没有办法指定两个站点。
No one ever thought of that as a reasonable use case. I actually cannot fix the iTunes or the RSS or any of that. The best I can do is provide just a download link on
从来没有人认为这是一个合理的用例。我实际上无法修复 iTunes 或 RSS 或任何这些东西。我能做的最好的事情就是在
www.programmingthrowdown.com So that's what I'll do. If you can't access the podcast and you're not in Russia, let us know. As far as I know, Russia is the only country in which we're banned. But there could be others. So if your buddy is telling you what a great episode
www.programmingthrowdown.com 上提供一个下载链接。所以这就是我要做的。如果你无法访问播客，而且你不在俄罗斯，请告诉我们。据我所知，俄罗斯是我们被封禁的唯一国家。但可能还有其他国家。所以如果你的朋友告诉你这一集有多棒
and you can't listen to it, your buddy should let us know. Your buddy should just send you the file. Yeah, and let us know. Yeah, but basically you can go to the website. I'm going to have alternate download links as soon as possible. All right, I think that's a wrap. Cool.
而你听不到，你的朋友应该告诉我们。你的朋友应该直接把文件发给你。是的，告诉我们。是的，但基本上你可以去网站。我会尽快提供备用下载链接。好吧，我想就这样了。酷。
All right, guys, have a good one, and keep sending us those emails. They're awesome. Thanks for all of your support on Patreon. Actually, the Patreon is growing. Let me see what it's at the Patreon is at $22 an episode so thank you guys
好吧，伙计们，祝你们过得愉快，继续给我们发电子邮件。它们太棒了。感谢你们在 Patreon 上的所有支持。实际上，Patreon 正在增长。让我看看它现在是多少，Patreon 每集 22 美元，所以谢谢你们。
that is awesome thanks for supporting us on Patreon we really appreciate that that's awesome and thanks for checking out the books that we recommend and all that good stuff send us lots of email thanks for checking out the books that we recommend and all that good stuff. Send us lots of email. Thanks for Yaroslav, Ashbooth, and Quang Nguyen for the questions and comments.
这太棒了，感谢你们在 Patreon 上支持我们，我们真的很感激。这太棒了，也感谢你们查看我们推荐的书籍和所有这些好东西。给我们发很多电子邮件。感谢 Yaroslav、Ashbooth 和 Quang Nguyen 的提问和评论。
And we'll catch you guys next month. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下个月再见。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的《Axo》。Programming Throwdown 根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。